The RN releases 1 new Malika Sorelle card,
1 new food,
1 food that makes a lot of talk,
1 new war take,
the food in 2nd position of the eséguist Malika Sorelle who is 1 intellectual
recognized by the former members of the high council
for immigration under Nicolas Sarkozy,
1 very bad news,
1 more for the Republicans,
1 intellectual known to have been close to François Fillon,
to defenders of Villepins.
It's 1 surprise,
it's 1 sarkozyst,
eh it's 1 fionnist.
It is nevertheless catastrophic for the Republicans.
..
And Bardella will be able with this food,
to drive out the defenders of Nicolas Sarkozy.
Malika Sorelle was born in France of Algerian parents,
she lived for 15 years in Algeria before settling in France.
She announced her candidacy in an interview for Le Figaro this morning,
insisting on her origins.
I find it beautiful that 2 children from immigration commit themselves
hand in hand to give back to France the love she gave them.
Deux-mille-vingt-sept.
It is in 3 years the baccalaureate Of the rallyings to the RN in order to
become ministrable in 1 to the government Bardella seems to have begun.
Malika Sorelle totally assumed her support this morning.
It was on these news For me the fact that I join the agilist uh carried
by Jordan Bardella was 1 evidence The party of Marine Le Pen,
it is 1 party that resembles the rpf of General de Gaulle,
which is social and national I find myself fully there because I am Gaullist.
So who is Malika Sorel?
This is 1 uh eseyist 1 engineer.
And on closer inspection,
his rallying to Bardella is no surprise.
Ten years ago,
she was alreadying with the extreme right.
She wrote,
for example,
on the very right-wing website,
the secular response Malika Sorel could also have chosen Zemmour.
He is a follower of the Great Replacement theory.
This is what she wrote on her blog on 26/01 last Yesterday,
at the station of saint-clou,
1 agent makes 1 announcement in direction of the passengers.
The next train to La Défense will leave from track B.
B. Like Bilel,
I thought of my inner fort.
This is a new sign of a Great Replacement that the elites neither,
but that the people see and hear every day.
Malika Sorelle has become known on TV sets,
especially at Frédéric Tadéi.
It is especially this clash on France 5 with Mazarine Painjo,
Mitterrand's daughter,
about immigration that has remained in the memories.
The cynical choices made for François,
who are denounced by who they are.
..
What happens to us?
Date of the beginning of the eighties,
the following years.
Father of which I am personally not your father Madam,
I speak exactly the logic of your book,
it is a pamphlet,
resentment,
we understand nothing But I would love to give you a solution.
No you don't understand anything,
but I didn't write it for you.
My book Mrs.
Malika Sorel.
On 1 RN list,
it is especially 1 very bad blow Republican who did not really need that.
The LR leaders have a hard time hiding it After this rally,
they have the seum.
Don't explain because the National Rally is exactly like Emmanuel
Macron practices individual debauchery that we will disappear.
It's not a story Of course the casting,
it takes skills We are not in the slogans,
in the war of personality.
1 little Uh From the past.
A figure of the past,
in, opportunistic...
Eric Sioti is obviously very upset and he has been
trapped in beauty by this question.
Month two thousand ten seven.
I was very happy to place her other than a hero with François Fillon
presenting her as 1 take of war,
she was Uh Among the hundreds of thousands of
French people who were there So uh No,
not really in fact she was just placed there next
to the chief and it was not innocent.
Look,
they think I'm alone,
they want me to be alone.